how's it going everybody it's Warren and
yesterday we got a brand new Chinese
Avengers in-game poster the poster has
some new heroes on it such as Valkyrie
and Wang and it has Thanos overlooking
everybody however one thing this poster
does have that no other posters have had
so far is the Fallen Avengers
we just received individual posters of
them with a new title avenge the Fallen
but we've never seen them grouped
together with the heroes that are still
alive it seems like the closer we get to
Avengers in game coming out the more we
see of the Fallen Heroes but perhaps the
most interesting thing about this photo
is that it appears that all of the
heroes dead and fallen are coming out of
the quantum realm I'll break down and
talk about what that means in this video
but if you're new to my channel be sure
to subscribe I do monthly giveaways
right now giving away 5 imax tickets if
you'd like to enter for your chance to
win all you have to do is be subscribed
to my channel like this video and
comment down below with your thoughts
and your favorite superhero or villain
the quantum realm has been very
mysterious in the MCU only appearing in
ant-man ant-man and the wasp and Doctor
Strange the quantum realm is just that a
dimension and a reality where all
concepts of time and space become
irrelevant and from what we know there
are only a few ways to enter this
dimension through magical energy
mystical transportation using a sling
ring or if by subatomic shrinking caused
by the Pym particles but the real
question is where can the quantum realm
take you one place it could take you is
soul world soul world was actually
mentioned in The Avengers in-game empire
exclusive that we got last week here's
an exact quote from the article from
Empire magazine as for the quantum realm
well what if those who were dusted
didn't die what if they were instead
stored in the soul stone the most
important of all of Thanos is designer
jewelry and what if there was a way to
get them back by infiltrating the stone
via the quantum realm as we know Marvel
does everything intentionally they don't
just say things everything is connected
in this article they talk about the dead
Avengers being in Soul world and a
possible way to get them out via the
quantum realm and then we get a new
Avengers in-game poster from Disney and
Marvel showing the heroes both alive and
fallen coming out of the quantum realm
in Doctor Strange we learned that he
can't see past his own death
so how did dr. strange see the Avengers
to feeding Thanos if he was dusted that
would require him seeing past his own
death which we know is not possible well
maybe it's just like the article said
what if those who were dusted didn't die
what if they're in the soul stone in
Soul world this seems to be the case and
lines up because again Doctor Strange
could not see past his own death and he
apparently dies at the end of Avengers
infinity war so he shouldn't have been
able to see past that moment if he truly
died which means he didn't die and dr.
strange has been inside of the quantum
realm before and dr. strange the ancient
one sent him through many mysterious
realms the quantum realm being one of
them and I'm sure he's had some practice
between the events of Doctor Strange and
the events of Avengers infinity war this
is straight from the Infinity Gauntlet
saga from the comics those who fall
victim to Thanos a snap end up in the
soul world and eventually they get out
so it looks like they might be taking a
little bit away from the comics we know
the Fallen Heroes come back to life
somehow many of the actors have already
spoiled this and we know the quantum
realm is supposed to be a huge part of
avengers endgame but what if it's
actually much bigger than time travel
what if it's used to bring back the
Fallen Heroes from the soul world again
the dusted actually being alive and not
dead but simply in the soul world lines
up with Doctor Strange not being able to
see past his own death he was able to
see the in the Avengers defeating Thanos
because he never actually died and then
we have the Empire magazine article that
mentions that the Fallen Heroes may be
inside of the soul world and the way to
get them back may be through the quantum
room and then we get this new poster
that shows all of the heroes both alive
and fallen coming out of the quantum
realm all evidence that points to the
fact that the people who were dusted are
not actually dead but actually inside of
the soul world and the Avengers will use
the quantum realm to go and get them
back it's looking like this is how the
Fallen Heroes are going to return in
Avengers in game but let me know what
you think about this do you think that
it all adds up for the Avengers to be
inside of the soul stone and to be able
to come back via the quantum realm let
me know your thoughts in the comments
down below
and again don't forget to subscribe
comment and like the video so you can
enter the giveaway and stay up to date
on everything relating to Avengers
endgame and Marvel as always thank you
all so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]